[Musique]
bonsoir les amis puis caché derrière un
énorme buisson
j'attendais le ciel était à l'orage les
lions avaient faim et bien nounours tu
fais tes devoirs de classe des devoirs
de classe me voyons patron j'écris un
livre le livre merveilleux des mémoires
d'un nounours c'est passionnant un futur
prix littéraire patron et je descends le
fino lui chez mes deux petits amis il
apprécie les belles lettres
le
pop up hop hop hop hop hop hop hop on
verra
sinon les coutures chicala tartari vraie
cuisine
[Musique]
mais ce n'est pas du tout un livre de
cuisine c'est le livre merveilleux des
mémoires d'un nounours madeleine
ministère je vais d'abord les crimes
mais écoutez un peu ce passage puis
caché derrière un énorme buisson chatron
dit le ciel était alors anges
sinon les lions avaient
alors nicolas au téléphone qui sait
j'entends rien et non
[Musique]
à l'eau vous désirez la pâtisserie pour
vous faire livrer des petits fours mais
vous faites erreur ma table au revoir
madame
ces gens qui sautent m2 numéro où on
était
payant oui les lions avaient au non non
ce n'est pas possible
c'est une erreur monsieur derrière
monsieur en matière on ne peut pas
travailler cinq minutes on
te fâche pas alors et des lions les
loups aveu fin
et alors
oh nous allons le lion avait fort
le loup est faux
[Musique]
mais voilà coeur parts et bien moi aussi
le repas était il a toujours fait je les
emmène à la campagne au calme
là au moins je pourrai écrire on paie
ici on ne peut rien faire de bon avec un
paragraphe eu
mais je vous rapporterait le livre de
merveilleux des mémoires d'un nounours
entièrement terminée
et c'est pour vous que je les curés à la
famille
olala ça recommence je me
[Rires]
promène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
o
o fuyons pas trop il est impossible de
travailler dans cette ville un instant
nounours je crois qu'il y à un avion qui
passe sous l'eau en route bonnut des
enfants faites de beaux rêves
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]